all right understanding medicare can get
a little complicated as we all know but
this spot
but the sponsor of the segment southwest
medical wants to break it down for you
take a look
dr alamo welcome back well thank you for
having me here this afternoon
yeah it's been a while we haven't talked
about medicare in
months here so let's break down the
basics for people who is eligible for
medicare
very good well that's a great question
and there's several categories so let me
go through them real fast
if you're at least 65 years of age get
you eligible for medicare advantage
if you're under 65 but have a qualifying
disability
that too can make you eligible for
medicare advantage there's another
criteria you can be
any age if you suffer two disease states
for example end stage real disease or
als
that too can make you eligible if you
move from another area and now you live
here in southern nevada
you can go ahead and jump on an m.a plan
at the end of the day though if your fee
for service medicare
65 and older with none of the things
i've mentioned
well there are enrollment periods and
what are the best steps for
choosing your medicare plan i know you
mentioned medicare
medicare advantage everybody needs to
look at their own situation there's
there's just not one plan for everybody
it's many plans for many people right
so look at look at yourself and see what
doctors and specialists do i need
what medications do i take what other
services do i want
you know you have to make sure that if
you're seeing currently certain pcps
or certain specialists make sure they're
on the plan
if you're already taking certain
medications by all means make sure
they're covered
there's other things too that some
patients may not realize that they need
or want you know dental vision hearing
fitness memberships
transportation services all those things
even though you may not be using them
now
you may want them in the future look at
the plans that offer those
exactly i see you guys say personalize
your choice so that's really important
there's a lot of plans out there so look
at each one
and look again the networks may be
similar they may be different what do i
mean by networks
i mean who are the doctors on uh what
services are there
look at each one and make the fit for
you
uh it's it's hard for someone to do this
on their own and that's why we have
independent agents and we also have a a
line which i think you're going to
socialize
where they can call and get advice ask
for help
and what other resources do people have
to get more information there's always
your physician
believe it or not your doctor is a good
source of information because
he is participating on some of these
plans ask him
ask your doctor what do you think would
work for me uh you can ask your staff
there's plenty of independent brokers
out there that can definitely get you a
good informed
information and here at united
healthcare and of course optum services
we have phone lines just for this but
i always go back to the number one
source ask your doctor
ask your doctor you can also go to
medicare.gov right that's easy enough
absolutely if you know how to operate a
computer which i've had to learn how to
do
thanks to southwest medical for
sponsoring this segment they have
locations across southern nevada just
call 702
242 to speak with an agent
or visit smalv.com